it was a bloody weekend for law
enforcement across the country liberal
crime policies facing intense new
scrutiny after several police officers
were gunned down the nypd is grieving
the loss of rookie officer jason rivera
who was shot and killed responding to a
domestic dispute his partner is now
clinging to life in a chilling detail
the gunman reportedly kept shooting at
the two officers even as they lay
motionless on the ground
in texas a manhunt is underway for a
suspect who murdered a deputy during a
traffic stop near houston and in
washington d.c a police officer shot and
wounded but was thankfully released from
the hospital democrats in new york being
pressed for solutions here's how they
are responding
we have to do more to fight the scourge
of illegal guns on our streets illegal
guns is an important first step
but we must also address bail reform new
york is the only state in the country
that does not allow the judge to detain
a defendant who poses an immediate
threat to the community and the white
house confronted over how it plans to
keep americans safe
does he know that after a year in office
people do not feel safe in this country
we have seen a surge of crime over the
last two years would you agree with that
as the murder rate nears a 25 year high
would he consider maybe trying something
different
trying something other than
supporting a massive plus up in funding
from his predecessor cracking down on
gun trafficking and gun violence which
is a major driver of the violence we've
seen across the country i think most
people who want to fight crime would
agree that's the right approach judge
janine
want to take a crack at that
i got to tell you you know i i have to i
have to sit here and shock when i hear
the governor of new york and the mayor
of new york you know talk about things
that can be done today or yesterday
before all of these cops are killed 59
percent higher numbers of cops killed in
2021 than in 2020. 73 cops killed in a
felonious assault murdered felonies
killings now let me tell you how to get
rid of guns and you get rid of the
people who are shooting the guns number
one you put them in jail and just like
they define deviancy down i think it was
daniel patrick moynihan we are so used
to things being so bad that if we allow
it to continue more then we're not going
to care about the crime that's happening
we're going to say oh it's not as bad as
last year it's not as bad as year before
the bottom line is this if you don't put
career criminals in jail and the guy who
killed the police officer in new york
city and the one who was presently
fighting for his life was a career
criminal with mental illness who had an
illegal gun and had an ar loaded under
his bed now that guy is a problem he
shouldn't have had those weapons and he
shouldn't be out of jail because what
we're doing now is even if he is
arrested he's being released immediately
you want to get rid of guns here's how
you do it you get a confidential
informant you get someone undercover you
do surveillance you get wiretaps you get
search warrants you join with the state
the local and the feds you i did it
myself as a d.a you put together a task
force don't talk about it do it and
don't defund the police and don't come
out you know i want to give mayor adams
the benefit of the doubt but don't come
out and say we're going to do this and
we're going to do that just do it now he
says we're going to put 30 percent of uh
80 percent of the city's violence where
it takes place in 30 police precincts
we're going to put a lot more manpower
person power no kidding it's called
comstat we did it years ago they gave
away broken windows they're letting
criminals run rampant these politicians
are hypocrites they don't want to jail
them they don't want to lock them up
they don't want to prosecute them they
don't have task forces and then they say
these guns are coming into new york
they're not made in new york so what we
have the toughest gun laws in the
country the governor says so what you're
not prosecuting and you're not jailing
them you're worthless your words are
worthless you're a liberal you're
defunding cops and you don't care about
the victims you never did and you never
will unless there's a funeral going on
this has reached the levels where it's
getting um asked at the white house
briefing and not just by fox news let's
take a look at trey gowdy from his show
last night some of the things he had to
say
americans have the right to be safe
because there is no liberty there is no
pursuit of happiness without life
you can't vote if you're dead you can't
sign up for a government program if
you're dead you can't build back better
if you're dead
so what is he doing about it
in particular last night one of the
things trey gowdy's went through is
several of the young women who have been
killed in just the last couple of weeks
well you can vote if you're dead and i
think we saw some of those i'm just
kidding dana yeah and biden has body
even called the family of any of these
victims i don't they haven't announced
anything i'm sure
another president would have called
this was an experiment this soft on
crime thing was an experiment we warned
them it was gonna fail and cause death
but they did it anyway it's like gain of
function
right we said it was gonna maybe kill
people but they risked it and then
everybody died you know where it started
and i don't care because my sister's not
watching it starts at the university
level these stupid professors have this
dumb idea that america creates criminals
because of
income inequality because of systemic
racism that is what creates criminals
and then when you incarcerate them dana
that's just going to harden the
criminals so we can't incarcerate them
we have to release them and give them
rehab now soros bankrolled it and now
what's the lesson you can't allow dumb
professors and a billionaire donor and a
power-hungry democrat in the same room
together because you're going to get
death and i don't know if they did this
on purpose to cause a crime wave a lot
of communists want to destroy america
from the inside or whether they're just
too stupid to know that their theories
that they think of don't actually work
when you put them into practice now
before they move on to another stupid
experiment that's going to get people
killed they should actually have to face
the pain they're causing
they have to get out of their penthouse
get out of their ivory tower because
there's blood on the streets and they're
not affected by it they should have to
go look at some of these family members
in their face feel the anguish see the
pain spend the night in north philly
spend the night on the south side see
what it's like see what their policies
are actually doing because until they
actually register some of that pain i
think they're going to still cause that
the democratic parties on the clock now
i mean they're now branded as the party
of death and crime that's not good for
business i want to ask harold do you
think that the democratic party is
understanding this moment
well i've said first of all it's good to
be around the table again i i i've said
on the show before i don't think this is
we should step back this is not a
democratic issue they're republican
governors who are overseeing this the
republican mayors in florida and
oklahoma and texas and other places that
overseeing this but there's no doubt in
the last year we have seen a movement
people who are more lines and democratic
parties suggesting we had to defund the
police the president of the united
states has said that's wrong the leader
of this city mayor eric adams ran on
saying that's wrong i'm not a democrat
that believes in that number two the
answer is yes if the if they're
democrats who believe that defending the
police and going soft on crime was
somehow another winning strategy they
should be they should that should be
refuted they should understand that's
not the right thing to do i give adam
some credit i do think you're right
comstat has been something we've always
known you look at the stats and figure
out where you apply the resources
hopefully he's able to do that i do hope
he also floods the subway with police
officers uh you have to have one victory
to get another victory dana has a story
we all have stories but dana has a
really personal story that just
reinforced this for all of us around the
table two you have to do something with
guns i understand the notion that guns
don't kill people kill people but you
got to have a gun to kill them and if
someone gets really angry they don't
have a gun they can't shoot me we have
to figure out ways to for democrats and
republicans that like to come together
around some of this ghost gun stuff and
we have to you know to your point their
laws they got to punish these people if
we have to build more prisons to put
them in and have mandatory minimums for
them we should have that one of the
things the white house has said a couple
of times is that well we're for more
money for cops like money would be
welcome i'm sure but it's not just that
it's the progressive prosecutors yeah no
you have alvin bragg who's basically not
prosecuting uh what he called the uh
when somebody is caught with a gun
they're released yeah and so there is no
there is a misdemeanor and that they
call it the iron pipeline these guns are
coming in nobody's being prosecuted if
you do actually put them away for a long
time that's that's a good thing to do
we're seeing i think this is a rebound
to a movement right you're seeing
intentional cop killings at a 20-year
high when you go and you look back at it
where was the they're comparing they're
going since 9 11.
that's a really weird comparison you
should remove 911 and see how far it
goes back right this is a rebound we
kind of predicted this uh
when there was this constant relentless
drum beat from the media and the far
left activists that devalued the lives
of law enforcement they never said like
huma you know these human lives aren't
worth it but if you said blue lives
matter
what were you called right you did
people had to apologize
when they said blue lives matter so now
we're in a situation where you're seeing
this sense that that these lives are
devalued and i you know it's weird how
like the left does not believe in free
will
but
they believe it if it's an inanimate
object
so a rock can hit an asian woman in the
head an suv could plow into a parade a
bullet can leave an elite lead leave an
illegal gun right it's like they talk
about gun possession
literally i think they mean it i think
the gun is possessed it's like
it's an autumn autonomous weapon there's
no actual criminal they're firing it
it's a possessed gun but then you think
about well what about the what about the
woman that was pushed in front of a
subway no gun what about the woman in
the furniture store that was a knife are
all of these just possessions you know i
don't know then you have a governor
saying despite all of her gun laws this
is happening well maybe it's because
you're not enforcing the gun laws you
have to so i came up with a word i
invented a new word it's called excuses
right it's it's it's an excuse disguise
me it's an excuse disguised as a
solution and the result is nothing
changes so what you always hear are
excuses when in fact you should be
hiring more cops you should be flooding
the area especially the subways you
should be locking up all of the illegal
gun users for a long time but the best
and most important thing we have to
start
reinstitutionalizing immediately restore
cash bail but we have to bring back stop
and frisk right now even if it's
temporary just to get the guns off the
street but the reinstitutionalization
getting the getting the criminally
deranged off the streets is going to do
a lot excuses excuse me
yeah what's a day without an excusion
yes exactly it's inexcusable
the transfusion hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else